here President Obama intends to lift the  Cuba terror designation this according  to the National Security Council of  course over the weekend President Obama  met historically with Raul Castro in  Panama the two shook hands and now he  will lift Castro asked for this he will  lift the terror designation he's  submitting a report to Congress on this  terror designation for Cuba according to  the National Security Council so really  an historic historic moment in historic  few weeks here for us Cuba relations but  he'll lift now the terror designation  and maybe it's pretty safe to say there  are no terrorists coming out of there